hallo mein name ist flughafen lieben
freunde wir schauen uns heute mal wieder
gemeinsam chat sales an und ich würde
sagen wir verlieren gar nicht langer
zeit denn das hier ist direkt der erste
jet feld und verschreibt eine person
alter ich bin gerade aufgewacht und ein
hund lag schlafend auf mir ich dachte du
hast gar keinen hund genau
das gegenteil dass das sprachenlernen
im nächsten schritt verlangt sich die
beiden personen bereits über den beruf
der jeweils anderen person unterhalten
und die dame antwortet nun ohne das
klingt aber richtig spannend ich arbeite
in der kita als erzieherin ist fluch und
segen zugleich aber ich liebe die
kleinen zwerge einfach cool
hattest du jemals schon mal einen furz
der ich überall hin verfolgt hat ok
jetzt bin ich wirklich sprachlos und da
meine lieben freunde kann ich einfach
nur sagen der mitmenschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend hallo hallo
alter hallo ja
als auch die pure dummheit es heute
wieder mit am start und bei diesen chat
verschreibt eine person ich habe gerade
herausgefunden dass ich einfach die
schule abbrechen und ein ganzes geld für
eine giraffe ausgeben kann hast du
dieses wochenende zeit
wtf und da denke ich mir auch wtf was
ihr euch jetzt allerdings wahrscheinlich
die ganze zeit schon denkt 'oh mein gott
ist das eine gescheite überleitung
gerade hier seht ihr oben ja schon werbe
video eingeblendet das sieht nämlich
ganz einfach daran dass das heutige
video freundlich unterstützen wird von
connectivity connected um ihr könnt ihr
mit euren freunden chatten allerdings
könnt ihr auch neue leute aus der
kompletten welt kennenlernen und zwar
das ganze entweder mit einem
öffentlichen profil oder sogar anonym
zudem könnt ihr auch noch
sprachnachrichten verschickten
videoanrufe sind auch noch möglich ist
soll man kann auf jeden fall eine
ordentliche menge mitmachen und ich
zeige euch jetzt mal ganz kurz so sieht
sonst müssen wir erstmal in die reihen
gehen und zwar sie mir einfach ein paar
in dem stories aufgelistet hier sehen
wir unsere konversation da habe ich halt
noch keine wäre ich habe keine freunde
dann seht ihr jetzt auch schon den
shuffle modus eingeblendet und ganz
rechts ist unser eigenes profil
da klicken wir jetzt einfach mal auf
erstelle dein profil dann müssen uns
einen benutzernamen überlegen
luca boyle 1996 den park nutzername ist
verfügbar
sehr gut endlich hoffe ich auch mal was
in meinem leben und nachdem ich dort
dann gerade nur noch ganz schnell meine
e mail adresse eingegeben habe um den
passwort überlegt habe seht ihr auch
hier schon mein profil gibt er jetzt
auch noch mein geburtsdatum angegeben
und das ist beim ein foto das bin ich
ich könnte mir gerne schreiben auf
connected app ist auf jeden fall mega
ist also wenn ihr sie euch herunterladen
wollen findet ihr einen link und in der
video beschreibung wir machen allerdings
jetzt auch schon direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten connected to fail und zwar von
diesem user bielefeld 3 4 1 er bekommt
die nachricht geschickt ich bin verwirrt
und whatsapp nummer nein ich bin keine
whatsapp nummer aber da steht das duo
aus bielefeld kommst ja bist du auch da
schickt mir deine adresse ohne link was
für eine adresse ohne link ich wohne in
bielefeld
woher kommst du münchen und du auch wie
kulig auf uns alleine oder in einer wg
ich wohne aktuell noch bei meinen eltern
aber nutzung übergang ich bin gerade aus
meiner sicht die ausgezogen und du ich
wurde alleine wieso zum übergang was war
denn mit seiner wg komme gerade aus dem
knast aber hat meine strafe abgesessen
keine sorge deshalb jetzt zum übergang
in kooperation mit unternehmen einfach
die ganzen klatschen wenn wir haben
richtig geil gegrillt gerade was gab es
bei dir so wichen quidditch kirche
quieken tisch verdammt salziger kuchen
mit 1 lauf und lauch dieses neue handy
macht mich verrückt verrückt
autokorrektur ist jetzt nicht in
allerbester freund farah wenn du sauer
bist benutzer einfach glitzer
teufelszeug hab das mal aus rache über
mein mitbewohner gestreuten nachts als
erschließt er hat den wichtigen termin
am nächsten tag und es ging nicht ab er
sah aus wie ein weihnachtsbaum bruder du
bist der du sprachen lernen
hey wie geht so ich fühle mich als wäre
ich von einem auto angefahren worden
aber nur von einem kleinen mini oder
smart oder so bobby car geht auch okay
mir gehts auch gut danke
das sind wieder hammer leute hier heute
auch dass hier herr eines mädchen dieses
crazy bad hier ist mein numbers calamari
calamari carla maria barbara hey hey nah
neh nah gut geschlafen herrenlos auf ich
hab geträumt dass ich mit meinen kindern
riesigen wiese aber meine kinder waren
nicht wenn die satire ein krokodil oder
sagen wir mal ein zweites kind eine grab
und an den ganzen seien ja gesagt zu
machen
ja mein rap album kommt bald tobt ist
das soll jetzt nicht komisch rüber
kommen aber ist sie schon mal
aufgefallen dass dinge auch nach farben
schmecken ist das ein scherz herein
wirklich jetzt die luft heute bei mir
schmeckt zum beispiel lila und manchmal
im freibad das schmeckt sie gelb ich
weiß nicht was du für pillen genommen
soll ich hätte gerne auch einer du musst
wissen was du willst pommes ich meine
auf lange sicht jede menge pommes dazu
würde ich einfach sagen nicht magst du
scharfes essen ja wieso ich liebe
scharfes essen aber mag das auch
wirklich nicht nur so gesagt wie ein
kumpel von mir weil er wollte nämlich
einen von meinen superscharfen napalm
hot wings abhaben und hat ihnen dann
weggeworfen erschreckt weil er so
schafer und dann angefangen zu weinen so
was kann ich nicht ertragen ich hasse
scharfes essen
ich hasse scharfes essen pilze und
energydrinks und sushi ich dachte das
sind die dinge die alle anderen menschen
über alles lieben hühner wie geht's dir
ganz gut und dir was machst du so mir
auch ganz gut kuscheln mit meint heißen
und du wärst heißen heißen meint
chihuahua
deine rechtschreibung ist schon nicht
die allerbeste aber dass du nicht mal
die rasse von einem rund richtig
schreiben kannst es ist jetzt echt ein
bisschen beängstigend den ganzen tag
schon so einen popel quer hängen
schreibt mir bei connected to me oh mann
ich war letztens in der bahn und dachte
mir ich vertraue ganz nett auf einmal
merkte ich wie jemand meine mitgenommen
hat jacke oh mein gott ich meine jacke
warum das hatten wir auch in den
whatsapp fels folgen schon so häufig
verwechselt die autokorrektur so häufig
das wort jacke mit dem wort
was ich allerdings auch nicht check ist
dieser fall und zwar und was machst du
so in deiner freizeit ich beobachte
gerne leute okay ich spiele fußball ich
weiß
jeden dienstag um 18.30 und freitags ab
19 uhr
wir hatten vor zwei wochen schon mal
sonst sorgt in seiner sms viel
geschichte was ist falsch mit euch und
könnt ihr bitte damit aufhören ich liebe
karpfen aber am liebsten mit erdbeeren
karpfen mit erdbeeren ja womit denn
sonst keine ahnung kartoffeln oder so
hält man ist kapseln gefüllt mit
marmelade und an silvester einer mit
senf oder so das sind krapfen eine runde
intuitiv wir haben mit meiner schwester
und zwar wenn meine schwester dann noch
ein bisschen jünger allerdings sollte
sie uns das wort hundehütte aufzeichnen
sie hat allerdings nicht hundehütte
gelesen sondern hundehütte und hat dann
hunde mit einem gut gemalt eine andere
sind 40 und warten sollte sie das wort
bärenhöhle pantomimisch darstellen der
da was die hat bärenhöhle verstanden
machen wir dann allerdings weiter mit
dem nächsten connected to fail und zwar
dass dieser hier
ich habe das gefühl du nimmst mich gar
nicht ernst das habe ich auch das ist ja
super da sind ja schon drei ich war mal
mit meinem besten freund feiern und er
hat sich dann mit einem edding einen
blitzer auf die stirn gemalt und gesagt
dass er harry potter heißt und dann die
mädels angesprochen unter dem deckmantel
dass er noch mädels 1 quilitzsch team
braucht und am nächsten tag musste er
gar nichts mehr davon und hat sogar
gefragt wer ihn an gemalt hat
ich bin stark dass sandra auch auf
connected to me unterwegs ist wenn im
krankenhaus und warte und du was machst
du im krankenhaus ist alles okay ja
alles gut mitbewohner gestern ein
bisschen zu viel getrunken weil er seine
ex so vermisst hat und dann ist die
stimmung gekippt
er war so voll dass er meine die
toilette wäre so was wie ein heiliger
brunnen und dann hat er daraus getrunken
ich bin richtig sauer heute ist mein
einziger freier tag diese woche und dann
noch ein saurer imogen egal du kommst
auch nicht ins krankenhaus nur weil du
außer toilette trinkst
doch das wäre allerdings auch schon zum
letzten connected to me fällt für die
heutige episode und zwar dass dieser
hier höher auf das war mit abstand die
krasseste und schlimmste nacht meines
lebens warum seit ich sechs bin schlafe
ich ab und zu aber halt immer nur in der
wohnung heute nacht habe ich den vogel
abgeschossen ich bin heute nacht aber
einfach aufgestanden und dann aus meiner
wohnung raus gegangen und aufgewacht als
ich unten auf der straße stand nur in
boxershorts ich hatte kein handy bin
meine wohnung nicht reingekommen hatte
nur boxershorts andere das war mitten in
der nacht ich konnte mich nicht mal aus
weiß das war alles einfach nur schlimm
und das
ist mir zum glück noch nie passiert denn
ich schlaf wie sonnenstein entspannt an
der stelle ich das heute wieder
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde die heutigen fans haben allen
der connected to me up stattgefunden
also ladet euch die es gerne runter ein
link dazu in der infobox und schreibt
mir ich als luca badoer wechseln meint
ich und meine puppen und wenn euch das
heutige video gefallen hat dann das
gerne einen daumen hoch da und schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare ob wir
brauchen auf einen zweiten teil
connected to me fels hättet wir befinden
uns nun allerdings auch im auto meine
lieben freunde oben findet ihr ein
smiley angewendet werde darauf könnte
meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren und er
verpasst solchen wundervollen videos
hier in zukunft nicht mehr und hier ist
ein anderes video verlinkt das ging
soeben auf meinem zweit kanal online
also klickt ja auch gern drauf link zu
connected zunächst in der jetzt schon
oft genug gesagt na ja